el comportamiento está escrito en los
genes
todos tenemos comportamientos innatos
todos los animales tenemos
comportamientos con los que nacemos
comportamientos que a lo largo de la
evolución de la evolución se fueron
haciendo cada vez más complejos en
muchos aspectos el comportamiento de
machos y hembras drive es si es distinto
y estas diferencias en el comportamiento
están dadas por diferencias en cableado
del sistema nervioso y estas diferencias
de cableado a su vez están establecidas
genéticamente
la agresión es un comportamiento que en
general es específico de los machos lo
vemos en especies que son muy distintas
que están alejadas evolutivamente la
forma en que pelean cada una estas
especies es diferente pero los
mecanismos son parecidos y las razones
son casi siempre las mismas los machos
pelean por hembras por comida o por
territorios
yo estoy agresión en moscas
lo que van a ver ahora es un ataque
un animal se va a incorporar y va a
dejar caer todo el peso de su cuerpo
sobre su oponente
el otro mientras tanto va a tratar de
escaparse porque estoy agresiones moscas
por el comportamiento que me interesa
entender es el mismo y el sistema es
mucho más simple entonces es como
estudiar una maqueta
a veces pasan el otro animal en lugar de
escaparse y se quedan y empiezo a pelear
y entonces se da algo que llamamos boxeo
algo muy importante del ataque es que
solamente los machos lo hacen los que
primero atacó es mucho más probable que
gane y los machos sólo atacan otros
machos y las hembras nunca atacan
entonces por qué estudiar comportamiento
en moscas porque tiene los mismos
comportamientos que nosotros las moscas
duermen comen cortan pelean aprenden y
recuerdan el sistema nervioso es mucho
más simple y además los genes que
intervienen estos comportamientos son
muy parecidos entonces estudiar
agresiones moscas nos permite entender
cómo se desarrolla este mismo
comportamiento en otras especies
un elemento clave a la hora de decidir
si cortejar o atacar es determinar el
sexo del otro animal todos los machos
están programados para decidir entre
cortejo o agresión pero las claves
sensoriales que usan para ver si lo que
tienen adelante es un macho o una hembra
son distintas por ejemplo a nuestra
especie las claves visuales son muy
importantes
pero lo que una mosca tiene delante es
esto
entonces cómo decides evidentemente de
alguna manera decide porque lo que va a
hacer en cada caso es muy distinto
en presencia de un macho que entra en su
territorio para empezar a atacar
y perseguirlo por todos lados hasta que
lo decida escaparse
en presencia de una guerra estrellada
como pueden ver literalmente me
arrastren alas
la persigue por todos lados le canta
hasta que finalmente la conquista
entonces la pregunta es cómo lo saben
cómo deciden cuáles son las claves
sensoriales que usan para decidir si
tienen que cortejar o si tienen que
atacar y si podemos identificar estas
claves podemos cambiarlas podemos
invertir esta decisión en insectos con
muchas especies son muy importantes las
señales químicas que se llaman feromonas
estas señales son producidas por el
animal y detectadas por el otro entonces
una cosa que decidimos hacer es invertir
las feromonas cambian el perfume para
hacer eso manipulamos la expresión de un
gen
se llama transformar transforma está
aprendido en las hembras y apagado en
los machos entonces algo que podemos
hacer es silenciar a transformar en las
hembras y forzar su atención a los
machos con esto masculinizados hembras y
semi izamos machos pero no en todos
lados vamos a manipular todo el animal
vamos a elegir algunas partes en
particular las células que hacen
feromonas entonces lo que podemos lograr
es hembras que tienen feromonas
masculinas o machos que tienen feromonas
femeninas y entonces vamos a ver qué va
a pasar cuando un macho normal no
manipulado se encuentra con una hembra
que tiene 0 monos masculinas
y lo que pasa es que la ataca cuando
ésta entra a su territorio él hace algo
que nunca haría frente una hembra normal
es empezar a atacarla
cuando hacemos el experimento recíproco
lo que encontramos es que los machos que
tienen feromonas femeninas son
cortejados
esto qué quiere decir que los machos
están genéticamente programados para
cortejar cuando encuentran feromonas
femeninas y para atacar cuando
encuentran feromonas masculinas
pero este comportamiento este
comportamiento innato que está cableado
en el cerebro cortejar a scheffer
hormonas femeninas atacar si hay
feromonas masculinas se puede cambiar
puede ser que un animal tan simple como
una mosca puede aprender de su
experiencia y modificar un
comportamiento que es innato algo que
está acá validado en su sistema nervioso
para hacer estas razones de preguntas
hicimos un experimento parecido otra vez
manipulamos transformar pero esta vez en
el cerebro de las hembras estas hembras
tienen todavía feromonas femeninas pero
se comportan como machos silenciamos
transformarse en el cerebro son hembras
agresivas no solamente que no les gusta
nada ser cortejadas sino que atacan
y entonces nos preguntamos qué va a ser
un macho cuando se encuentre con una
hembra que tiene feromonas de hembra
pero es agresiva y lo primero que va a
hacer es cortejarla por todos lados la
persigue la persigue le arrastre la ala
le canta pero llega un momento que
decide cambiar su comportamiento en un
momento de tanto cortejarla y que no
pase nada y que ya encima lo ataque y se
vuelve ya y la termina atacando esto
quiere decir que aún un animal tan
simple como una mosca puede aprender de
su experiencia y modificar su
comportamiento y no sólo esto si no hay
peleas entre dos machos siempre se dan
que hay un ganador y un perdedor después
de que un macho perdió muchas veces lo
que ocurre es que suprime este
comportamiento deja de pelear
esto quiere decir que aún en un animal
tan simple como una mosca el
comportamiento está en los genes pero la
capacidad de aprender de la experiencia
y modificarlo también